The joe rogan experience.
Oh yeah.
I want you to do more movies,
man.
I really enjoyed Freddy got fingered.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Thank you.
You went out there with that man.
You took a crazy chance.
Yeah.
I think it shocked a lot of people.
They didn't know what to do with it,
you know,
because it was so out there,
but it's like it was one of
the ultimate stoner movies.
If you're a stoner,
what?
Go get Freddy.
If you mean people like you know,
a lot of people haven't,
haven't really heard an
enough good reviews of it.
It's really fucking funny girl.
Thank you.
Voted that all day.
I do that scene with the
baby when the giving birth.
It's fuck I want to say anymore.
I don't want to ruin it.
I don't know.
A very similar in a way to your comedy.
Yeah,
no.
Let me,
let me tell you.
It's a thing.
The,
thank you for saying that
because you know when you,
when you,
you get thrust into this situation where
all of a sudden I had an opportunity to
make a movie to write.
I wrote it,
it was obviously was this trying to make
the stupidest movie we could think of
right now.
Let's make it the stupidest thing ever.
And then,
you know,
the studio at the time,
I had all this opportunity to make this,
they said,
okay,
they had all these directors
I said I want to direct it to,
so then they let me do it,
right?
So now I'm swinging blooding
babies around and you know,
jacking off elephants
and stuff and you know,
getting insight here,
carcasses and doing all this stuff.
Right?
And then,
you know,
you're working on this
thing for like a year,
right?
You know,
you're working on this
thing for a year nonstop.
Uh,
you know,
you're casting it,
you're picking all the props,
you're making sure all the way the guts
that come out of that deer carcass look
like rubber to me.
And then the,
the prop guys like,
well,
we're going to put some blood
on it and it's going to,
and I go,
well,
let's see what that looks like.
And they do it.
And you look at it and you're like,
no,
it still looks like some rubber.
We've got to get some real guts.
And they're like,
well,
we don't know how we're going to make
real guts come out of the carcass when you
cut it.
And then they go,
well,
they go off and these are like
people that are professionals,
you know,
and they go off and they come
back the next day and to go,
okay,
we've rigged up this compressed air that
we're going to put in the back of the
taxidermy dear.
You're going to run your
knife down the slit.
It's gonna shoot out real pig guts that
we've got at the butcher shop and I'm
draped and pig guts and
I'm doing all this stuff,
all this stuff right?
And you're thinking,
okay,
this is crazy.
This is going to look crazy.
Then the movie comes out,
everybody like,
you know,
basically,
reams you like,
uh,
you know,
you've never been reamed before
in your life at this point.
I mean,
local papers and people and you and you,
and you feel completely
kind of confused about it,
right?
Because you're thinking,
shit,
I thought it was pretty fucking funny.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
Right.
So then the,
the fun thing about it is after that
initial weekend and the whole sort of
everybody talking about your
movie being crazy and you know,
disgusting and all this stuff,
you a,
you know,
I've been on tour this year doing
standup and it's been so much fun because
there's a lot a,
of a nut jobs out there
in the world that like,
that let that love the movie and there,
and then it's part of my show now.
And when I do my standup,
I do a little guitar at my show in
the middle and I seen a couple like,
Daddy,
would you like some sausage?
I sing that with everybody,
sings it with me.
And then people start shouting
out some of their favorite pets.
But I'm surprised I went
all across Australia,
Canada.
Uh,
next month I'm going to
be in a Toronto Bellville,
um,
uh,
Hamilton and London,
Ontario.
And,
uh,
people come to the shows and,
you know,
are,
are shouting out all
these things from Freddie.
Got To saucing.
It feels a lot.
I guess what I'm saying is,
thanks for bringing it up,
but this is great to be out and actually
getting all this positive feedback
about the movie because I was made to
feel like this is word or somebody who,
this is what I know.
You're a victim of a
pre-internet review system.
It was a bunch of fogy old douche bags
and you know the way people looked at
things was,
you know,
you couldn't just when,
what year was Freddy got fingered?
It was 2001 yeah.
Who the fuck was on
the Internet back then?
You know what I'm saying?
It wasn't the same as 2010 and
the thing that doesn't attend,
you get your reviews from,
ain't it cool.
Dot news.com like that kind of shit.
Like I always go to Fandango or something.
I get my reviews online.
I want to use this moment as a,
as a real,
there's a real opportunity for me to
actually talk about this for a second.
Okay.
I directed this movie,
but he wrote this whole thing.
Everybody freaks out on it.
It's Pre-internet,
right?
I,
the other day I went and
I looked at a Netflix.
Okay.
At the,
of the reviews of the movies,
right?
So I did this just two days ago and I
looked at the review as a pretty good
finger.
And the point of making that movie
was to kind of like be polarizing,
right?
It was supposed to be ridiculous.
It was done in a way where I think
that 50% of the people who watch it are
definitely going to hate it more than
anything they've ever seen in their entire
life.
And that was the goal to,
you know,
and the Joe is obviously the other 50%
of the people are laughing at the 50% of
the people that hate it.
And it's,
that's,
that's the joke,
right?
So yeah,
I went on Netflix and you're
reading the reviews and it's,
it's pretty much 50 50
people are giving it either,
you know,
a good review or the worst review you've
ever read in your life back and forth,
back and forth.
And these people are just
arguing with each other about it.
And I'm looking at it.
Here we are 10 years later after I made
this thing and looking at these people,
having these passionate
arguments completely on
opposite ends of the spectrum.
That's pretty funny.
So I like that.
Go read the reviews on this sequence.
I really,
truly believe that if
that movie came out today,
it would be an internet phenomenon.
People would be so into it.
I think it's a,
it was a fucking fun,
crazy.
Make it three d
[inaudible].